à
[Musique]
moi c'est presque pas suffisant par
rapport à toutes les actions aujourd'hui
et tout ce que l'on ressent aujourd'hui
sur la société sentiment d'insécurité ce
sentiment d'inégalité également je pense
que aujourd'hui il faut bien consacrer
un mois entier pour ce genre de choses
[Musique]
la programmation s'adresse bien sûr à
toutes les femmes on commence aussi je
dirais à solliciter auprès des collèges
même au niveau je dirais des écoles
élémentaires puisqu'on commence à parler
aussi de tous ces sujets là haut niveau
je dirais des enfants et je dirais aussi
auprès de ces messieurs puisque
aujourd'hui je considère que la société
doit être sensible à ces sujets là pour
des parties zen avec des soins des mains
avec des toute une série d'actions est
tourné vers elle et puis nous aurons
aussi des autrices qui vont venir
puisqu'on dit hauteur mais on dit aussi
aux tristes qui vont venir travailler
avec nous sur sur le travail aussi de
l'égalité femmes hommes au niveau du
sport puisque le rugby le foot comme je
vous le disais travailler avec nous et
puis il y aura des conférences et puis
aussi des petits déjeuners où nous
allons pouvoir échanger avec la
population
les partenaires bien sûr ce sont tous
les services de la ville puisque on
travaille aussi bien avec les quartiers
en politique de la ville avec les femmes
des quartiers mais également avec nos
seniors dans la maison rosso et avec
toutes les associations qui sont
partenaires de nos actions par exemple
je vous donne un exemple c'est le
football club de plaisir le flop puisque
nous avons aujourd'hui des équipes
féminines qui travaillent avec nous ce
sont toutes ces actions que nous mettons
en place pour que au sein des agents de
la collectivité nous puissions avoir un
travail
égalitaire et de reconnaissance
égalitaire des femmes par rapport aux
hommes
[Musique]